hello I'm epically sourced andrew heaton
and you're sustainably watching mostly
weekly put down the tide pod
congratulations we survived the
government shutdown this is our 19th
shutdown since 1976 when we get 20 we
get a free coffee but brace yourself for
another government shutdown and another
and another and another
Congress avoided a shutdown this time
due to the revolutionary technology of
and I'm not making this up a talking
stick
apparently Congress couldn't talk about
immigration policy without a talking
stick to determine who can talk which is
juvenile and I think we can all agree
that we excuse me I have the Talking
Stick Sara please please would you
please thank you thank you
Congress stop the shutdown this time by
passing what's called a continuing
resolution which just means the
government funding continues as is until
Congress actually passes a budget
continuing resolutions work but not well
they don't account for reallocating
funding if the value of programs are
shifted or if they can be retired and
sadly the last time we went an entire
year without resorting to a CR was 1997
we've been running on continuing
resolutions since october and presumably
will be running on them up until the
winfrey administration takes over now
it's true that many libertarians view
the federal government is one big human
resources department with guns and i can
understand why you might think a
shutdown would be a cause for
libertarians to celebrate but you'd be
wrong
yes the government is bloated and
inefficient and we should amputate
several of its appendages but a
government shutdown doesn't actually
accomplish anything it doesn't shrink
the size of federal agencies it doesn't
save money it's even counterproductive
to limited government in the long term
let me explain no shrinkage as soon as
the federal government reboots all the
government agencies drug wars and
bureaucrats are still there in fact a
lot of them never left here are just
some of the government functions
unaffected by shutdowns
[Music]
expense nor do we save any money during
a government shutdown Social Security
entitlements and defense spending don't
get their funding cut or reformed Plus
like something out of The Twilight Zone
government shutdowns actually cost
America more than if the government had
just stayed active portrait of a country
where a government costs more to
shutdown than to actually run
we're not essential employees get paid
in the future for past and activity a
country within the twilight zone and
shutdowns are expensive according to
Standard & Poor the US economy lost
twenty four billion dollars during the
two weeks of the 2013 government
shutdown
that's 1.5 billion per day how shutdowns
caused mass inefficiencies that take a
heavy economic toll on the private
sector the shutdown delays business
transactions requiring federal permits
it postpones court cases and it
restricts travel by withholding
passports plus museums and parks can't
collect fees which takes revenue from
the agencies and hurts tourism in 2013
about 40 percent of non-military federal
employees were considered non-essential
and they were furloughed which is to say
temporarily laid off but as soon as
these forlorn furloughed federal
employees come back they get back paid
in other words a government shutdown is
basically a mandated paid vacation for
federal employees so the government
winds up spending the same amount that
it would have if it stayed open
but without providing the services our
tax dollars are paying for that means
veterans may not get their checks
unemployment benefits stop tax rebates
cease and vacations to our finest
national monuments get scuttled backlash
the government shutdown may even hurt
the cause of small government in the
long run when societies lose faith in
their institutions they tend to embrace
authoritarianism when the government
doesn't work people tend to respond by
seeking you guessed it more government
it's like trying to drink yourself sober
or dealing with playground bullies by
giving one of the bullies a chainsaw it
would be great if we shrunk the
government but the government we have
should be leaned and efficient helpful
and simple sort of like a talking stick
the way towards limited government is
through debate and legislation and
giving people and markets time to adjust
shutdowns are the
opposite of that they're a combination
of partisanship squabbling and
incompetency hashtag Kardos wahpeton say
the only way past perpetual shutdowns is
if our elected leaders act like civil
adults trying to solve a common problem
bipartisanship
[Music]